when it comes to women and  not just women but mainly in this  conversation when something is brought  against them they don't take the time to  listen and look into what it is this  person is saying is instantly like you  said something against women we're going  to try to get you off as quickly as  possible instead of sitting down  listening to what he's saying taking the  bits that are like okay maybe that's  true and other bits be like Ah that's  not true and taking an enemy and being  like how can I better myself from this  conversation that this man had even  though his approach may not be something  that I like to hear but what his words  are saying is something that I may need  to hear that's why